Okay! Let's finish our derivation of the
countdown problem. We started out
with a very simple brute force solution.
Then in the second step we took
the generation process and we made
sure that we
never generate expressions that were
invalid.
And what we are going to do in this third
step is we are going to
shrink the search space by leveraging
algebraic properties of an expression.
In particular
the fact that multiplication is
commutative
and the fact that 1 is the neutral
element
for multiplication.
These are the properties we are going to
use. Multiplication
is commutative and
1 is the neutral element for
multiplication. Alright.
Here is the previous definition
of whether an
expression was valid. And remember:
An expression was valid when the
numbers of which it was composed were
positive.
When we added two
values, well, that is valid, because
adding two positive numbers
gives a positive number. When we subtract
two numbers
the result is positive when the first
number is larger than the second.
Multiplication of two positive
numbers is always positive.
And here we had to make sure that
we remained within the integer domain.
In this case, instead of just
returning True
what we do now is we say we want
x to be less than y. So we are going
to make this thing biased.
Adding x to y is valid
if x is less than y and we are
going to do the same
for multiplication. And now
we also want to say that
if the x is 1
we don't consider this thing valid.
So we are throwing that one away. So
what we did
is we biased the representation. We
say we always want the one on the left
to be larger than the right and by that
we have
eliminated Add y x as a valid
expression.
So you see this is a clever trick. If x
and y are the same, it is still valid
but if x is less than y, less or equal
than y
we have eliminated the
commutative expression Add y x.
Good. And then we also
want to use the case where
x or y is 1. So this takes into
account
the commutativity of multiplication
and addition
and the fact that 1 is the neutral
element
of multiplication. And finally
also when we divide by 1
that's the same as x. When we
apply this very simple extension to
the tests
it has quite dramatic results. So when we
look at the solutions
for this, there are now only 250,000
valid expressions.
So that is about 20 times less than
before.
And when we look at the solutions
there are about 16 times less,
because all the solutions that we had
were duplicates of each other, or all the
solutions, there were many duplicates
in those solutions. So when we run this now
it finds the first solution
in 0.02 seconds, but even more important
it finds all the solutions in under
half of a second.
Really all the
problems from this TV program
are solved within half a second.
And we started out with all solutions
being about
44 seconds, so this is quite a dramatic
improvement.
And you see that it was not that
difficult. We made two small steps
starting with an obviously correct
solution that was slow
and then we refactor it to remain correct
but become fast. And this is the way
Haskell programmers like to work.
You start with something that is right
and then you make it better.
Great, thank you so much, happy hacking.
Make sure you do your homework and then
see you next week.